I'm skipping a grade and going abroad to study
This is my last school festival I wish
Kanda days could last forever
Shinomiya Kaguya Kokura Setai I've been thinking that all along Shinomiya
Actually, I didn't think there was a good person for Anna, but I
accepted that there are people like seaweed in the world.
ni
2 If I don't get
told by Nishinomiya until the last day of the school festival,
I'll think that casual comparisons and concepts are really attractive.
No,
I'm going to go to the real silver that's being tested Do you
understand Shinomiya's furniture store
?  I can't
move forward,
even if it means I'm
undefeated Come on, Mia
ani, who's about to die at the start of the game  I
want you to confess to me I want to
delay the camera sumo